mientras que para los miles de
refugiados que han huido a países como
este polonia los avances en el proceso
de paz son una noticia positiva en el
terreno en ucrania la situación todavía
es difícil hoy en la ciudad de mi hijo
la llave en el sur del país al menos
nueve personas han muerto tras que un
misil impactara contra uno de los
principales edificios de esta urbe según
han denunciado las autoridades de kiev y
también en la región de hearts o en otra
ciudad que ha sido al estado el centro
de los combates en las últimas semanas
un alcalde de esta región ha sido
secuestrado según han denunciado las
autoridades de ucrania mientras que en
la capital en quiebra se siguen oyendo
las sirenas antiaéreas se siguen oyendo
las explosiones y a pesar de que no hay
un avance de las fuerzas rusas en a los
poblados cercanos a esta ciudad todavía
hay informaciones de escaramuzas que
continúan produciéndose
es también en estas horas